are you liking the heroes that injustice
to as announced so far well you can't
forget about the villains which is
exactly what the fighting games latest
trailer is all about and man do they
look awesome I'm Matt and this gamespot
news update is all about the bad boys
the latest trailer reveals two new
fighters and gives us our first good
look at bein who we've seen short
snippets of in previous videos next we
get the reveal of Captain Cold as part
of the fighting roster he showed up in a
story trailer previously and it was
unclear if we would be able to play him
or not we also get another look at
Gorilla Grodd but the trailers big new
in veiling is Batman's iconic villain
scarecrow and he looks absolutely nuts I
mean look at him he's one creepy dude
anyway we'll keep you updated as more
new fighters are announced so make sure
to LIKE and subscribe to be the first to
know about all of the injustice to
reveals injustice to launches for ps4
and xbox one on May 16 other characters
that have recently been revealed include
Black Adam firestorm and Swamp Thing
injustice to director ed boon said
earlier this year that the game would
feature more obscure characters and the
roster definitely seems to reflect that
you can check out the full list of every
confirmed fighter on gamespot com but if
you want to see them in action go take a
look at robin and dr. fades character
breakdowns on our channel
[Music]